feeling
the oldest answer the man in the middle
will be Scotland's next first Minister
tons of use of selective as the new SMP
leader I have been given the results of
the party leader election 2023 moments
before the room was on a knife edge
cameras fixed on candidates some
struggling more than others to disguise
their displeasure I therefore
Scottish national party leader
and just as I will lead the SNP in the
interests of all party members
not just those who voted for me so I
will aim to lead Scotland in the
interests of all of our citizens
whatever your political allegiance The
polls were suggesting throughout the
contest that you of the three candidates
were the most incompetent weak and
untrustworthy how are you going to turn
that around I've got every confidence
not just my own ability but frankly the
ability of the exceptional sap team I'm
a Democrat members have made their views
known this was a bruising battle for the
SMP candidates squabbling in public a
far cry from the discipline of the early
days of the sturgeon government I think
it's a been a great contest which has
created space for robust and Frank it
exchanges is Hamza Yusuf trustworthy
I believe so yes I give him my sport
would you serve in his cabinet we'll
wait to see if your first major the
nation watched the new chapter unfold
observing their decision makers edging
closer to office I was disappointed to
get the in I thought the woman
was
seeing one or two things none of them
were very good
probably ahead of the three he deserved
it Hamza yusuf's Victory here in
Edinburgh was narrow he now needs to
Pivot his position to appeal to The
Wider public across Scotland and on
policy matters he's in favor of making
it easier to change gender something
Westminster is blocking and Yusuf is up
for that fight in court putting him on a
constitutional crisis from day one and
when it comes to the matter of
Independence his critics say his
Premiership as first Minister means that
will be kicked into the long grass the
real job of governing now begins as
Hollywood votes for its new first
Minister on Tuesday in a country divided
on its political path